another song that everybody loves at
nine to five and you talk about
that song just came out of being very
bored
on on set well actually i wouldn't say
it's being very bored it's just
there i was bored always in between
because they have so much time
between setups with lighting and you
just sit around and what are you going
to do
you can't really get you know into a
good book or
anything because you don't know when
they're going to call you so on the set
i would watch everybody because this was
all about women in the workplace
and part of my deal with jane fonda if i
was in the movie that i would get a
chance to write
the theme song so i didn't have a chance
to get my guitar go back to the trailer
all the time so i would just kind of
roam around on the set
watching everything that was going on
and i would take my nails
because with acrylic nails it makes like
a percussive sound can you hear that
yeah yeah yeah but anyway it sounds like
a typewriter too so i just started to
write little words and things that i
would see and things i would think that
would fit with that
day-to-day nine-to-five job getting up
and drinking your coffee stumbling to
the kitchen and all
so then i'd go back at night into my
hotel room
and then put those things down but i did
that over a period of time
and after we recorded the song i brought
all the girls down that was on the show
and i played my nails so i have a credit
on the back of the album that says
nails my dolly by
[Laughter]
hey golly dolly how did you manage to
play the guitar so well
with those nails well pretty good
actually i've learned to do it i really
when i'm serious about my songwriting
i take these off and follow them down
and you know really right
but i've learned to work them with these
work great as pigs there's no problem
with this then
but these are the ones i have a problem
but i've learned to to do open tuning
mostly for the when i'm riding and stuff
but if i'm really serious about it i
just have to slow them down
well lovely to see you where are you
dolly well i
am in nashville in my little studio
where i work a lot of my things and
especially now that we're all uh kind of
confined to little areas
so we have a little studio set up and so
we're just broadcasting
right around home okay but you are now
slowly
uh emerging from lockdown am i right in
thinking dollywood is reopened has it
it did actually we've been in business
now for a few months and we're doing
really well of course we're not as up to
speed
as when you were there last time but
we're doing good and we've got our fall
season and our christmas season coming
up so
we're we're doing well we're happy about
that
and uh anyone worrying about christmas
2020
uh i'm here to tell you dolly parton has
saved
christmas 2020. uh because uh you've got
a new
album is this not true i do and it's
called a
holly dolly christmas see
christmas safe but we have a lot of
really wonderful things that some
classic country
uh classic christmas songs like uh i saw
mommy kissing santa claus holly jolly
christmas and of course i wrote a few
new songs
we just got a lot of wonderful people on
it it's a fun
album and i just figured we'd all be
closed in more
this year than ever for christmas so i
wanted to do something special
oh thank you and i believe you're going
to be back closer to christmas with a
very special
uh seasonal performance for us is that
right yes i got something special for
you
a surprise dolly pardon i love you
uh the christmas album is out now the
book is out on the 17th of november
and uh we'll see you closer to christmas
for a special
uh performance uh good night yes you
will
thank you so much
you